the opening scene features a beautiful
woman named Laura Bernie who is enjoying
her time on the beach she seemingly has
an idyllic life and the perfect marriage
with her husband Martin who is a
successful Boston investment counselor
they live in a massive summer Villa near
a beach one day the two get welld
dressed and attend a social Gathering
despite being with different groups of
friends their chemistry seems to be
going on as they keep gazing at each
other after the event the two return
back home and make out life is awesome
the end the next morning Martin notices
a misplaced towel in the bathroom so he
brings Laura there and reminds her not
to make such a mistake again afraid of
the consequences Laura then rechecks
everything in the kitchen even aligning
the food cans with utmost accuracy later
on Martin goes out to meet a neighbor
who praises Laura's Beauty saying that
he has seen her numerous times looking
out of the window say my wife is hot
again and I slap you says Martin
following this they talk about the
neighbor's boat and Martin expresses his
fondness for sailing hearing this the
neighbor invites him and Laura for an
evening sale Martin agrees despite
knowing that his wife is afraid of water
and that she can't swim Martin then
returns home and slaps Laura hard oh man
he does slap before kicking her as well
he is enraged that someone else is
having pleasure in seeing his wife at
this point it's revealed that beneath
Martin's Charming handsome exterior
there is an obsessive and controlling
person who's been physically emotionally
and sexually abusing Laura throughout
all of their nearly 4-year marriage in
the aftermath of the assault Martin in a
recurring pattern apologetically showers
her with Flowers and Gifts this time he
gives her a red dress as a gift he
undresses her and makes her wear that
dress it seems clear that she is not
comfortable with this treatment shortly
thereafter he again forces himself onto
her and her face says everything by now
the following day during lunch Laura
expresses her wish to do a full-time job
in a library but Martin doesn't allow
her pointing out that she's already
working as a part-timer at a bookstore
she then mentions how she wasn't even
allowed to visit her mom's funeral 6
months ago in response Martin tells her
not to argue because he doesn't want to
ruin the mood for the night in the next
scene the couple and the neighbor set
out for the sale before long a severe
storm unexpectedly rolls in causing
Martin and the neighbor to struggle to
control the vessel at one point the boat
hits a large wave which sweeps Laura
overboard this freaks Martin out and he
starts searching for her in the water
while screaming her name after an
extensive Coast Guard search they only
find her safety vest and Laura is
presumed dead from drowning later Martin
returns home and rages out blaming
himself for the loss of his wife as he
sh as he should the next day a funeral
procession takes place but Martin is
still in disbelief in an unexpected turn
of events Laura is revealed to actually
be alive flashbacks show that she jumped
overboard and swam through through the
water thanks to the secret swimming
classes she took while pretending to go
to her job upon surviving the storm she
rushed back home grabbed a bag that she
had already prepared and dawned a wig
before boarding a bus it turns out that
she had it all planned in order to
escape her husband's abusive and
obsessive acts and she lived happily
ever after the end no okay at present we
see Laura on a bus heading to Cedar
Falls Iowa on her way an elderly woman
officer some fruits initiated a
conversation Laura then shares her
tragic story of how she faked her own
death to escape her abusive husband she
should have probably kept that a secret
she also discloses that she's going to
see her mother who turns out to still be
alive previously she had told Martin
that her blind stroke impaired mother
named Khloe had died but that time Laura
had secretly moved her to an Iowa
nursing home as the bus enters Iowa
Laura finally has a big smile on her
face she feels so happy as if she's been
released from prison following this
Laura adopts a new name Sarah Waters and
rents a house on that name she then
starts cleaning organizing and coloring
her house eventually making it her small
Paradise during the evening time she
looks at the Sunset and cherishes the
present moment she starts living her
life the way she wants she misplaces
towels after showering and disperses the
food cans on the kitchen shelf she's a
badass Rebel and she loves it on the
other hand Martin roams the seashore
when a broken piece of bulb injures his
feet he looks around and notices that
several light bulbs are broken it's
actually broken by Laura in order to
facilitate her Escape one day Laura
notices a guy named Ben Woodward from
her neighborhood watering his plants in
the garden later that night she goes
outside and starts stealing some apples
from his garden right then Ben shows up
and tells her that she can be arrested
for stealing she requests him to allow
her to because she's making an apple pie
hearing this he asks her to make a deal
I won't call the cops if you give me a
Sloss of that sweet pie but she drops
all the apples and walks away claiming
that she doesn't make any deals he
follows her home and offers her the
apples apologizing for his way of
approach he then introduces himself as a
Drama teacher at a local college but
when he asks about her she pretends that
it's too late and has him leave in the
next scene Martin is at his workplace
when he receives a phone call from a
woman at a sports club offering
condolences for Laura perplexed Martin
questions how the call knew his wife as
Laura never went to any sports club the
woman then discloses that Laura used to
come there every morning for her
swimming classes upon learning of this
Martin senses something am Miss and
drives home to check on Laura's
belongings after hours of inspection he
discovers her wedding ring which she
dumped earlier but forgot to flush in
the toilet this makes him suspect that
she might have faked her own death and
might still be alive meanwhile Laura
goes to Ben's house to share a homemade
apple pie he invites her inside to have
dinner together as they prepare for it
they have a brief conversation through
which Ben learns that she is looking for
a job he offers to help her get one but
she refuses as she doesn't seem to have
any qualification documents with her
amidst this he notices a wound in her
head and speculates that she's had a
troubled past he tries to ask her about
it but she abruptly changes the topic
after this Ben asks her for her name one
more time and she finally answers Sarah
Waters starting from the fall ing day
Martin starts a thorough investigation
regarding Laura he goes to a nursing
home posing as a detective and learns
that Laura paid all the bills and took
her mother away 6 months ago hearing
this Martin's suspicion grows even
stronger obviously he then hires a
private investigator and offers him a
huge sum of 20,000 big buggies if he
manages to find her in Iowa Ben helps
Laura in securing a job at a library as
they walk out he asks for her real name
he doesn't believe that Sarah is her
name because she won't answer when he
calls her by that name regardless Laura
doesn't tell him the truth and says that
she may just not have been listening at
this point Ben confesses that he likes
her and asks her to give him a chance
however Laura who has a traumatized past
doesn't want to be in any relationship
so she turns him down a few days later
the entire town is celebrating
independence day amidst of the crowd Ben
spots Laura and apologizes to her for
the earlier in incident however she
suggests that they forget everything she
then opens up about her mother whom she
hasn't seen in 6 months on the same
evening Ben invites Laura to his Studio
where they share a joyful time together
he lets her try different drama costumes
and they engage in a romantic dance to a
song it appears that they are enjoying
each other's company and are bonding
really well the atmosphere eventually
takes a romantic turn as they share a
kiss but when Ben attempts to escalate
the intimacy Laura is reminded of her
traumatic past making her feel really
uneasy as a result she resists and
pushes him away in the meantime Martin
locates Chloe at a new nursing home
which finally confirms his suspicions
evil douchebag closing in the next
morning Ben is sitting outside his house
wearing a sad expression and blue balls
shortly after Laura comes to him and
starts talking about her abusive husband
she also reveals how she faked her own
death in order to escape from him in
response Ben reassures her safe and
provides a consoling hug later on he
assists Laura in disguising herself as a
man before she goes to visit her mother
in the nursing home she approaches her
mother with a lullaby that she used to
sing to her as a child Chloe is
delighted to meet her daughter after so
long as they Converse Laura reveals that
she left Martin and that she is now
living a happy life she also tells her
about Ben and his profession as a Drama
teacher that sounds like he doesn't make
any money dear meanwhile Martin is also
at the nursing home trying to gather
information about Khloe's visitors as he
goes to drink some water from a fountain
there's Laura in front of him however he
doesn't recognize the disguised version
of her just as Laura leaves a staff
member tells Martin about a visitor he
then rushes outside to stop her but she
has already driven away Laura returns
home and she is so happy that she jumps
into Ben's arms and kisses him
afterwards Martin poses as a police
officer to Khloe he fabricates a threat
towards Laura and says that they have to
find her immediately medely the old lady
who needs to stop falling for costumes
doesn't know where to find her but she
tells him about Ben who works as a Drama
teacher in Cedar Falls college with this
information at hand Martin locates Ben
and starts tailing him secretly later
that evening Martin follows Ben to an
amusement park where he finally sees
Laura he is filled with jealousy and
anger when he Witnesses the two kissing
no Upon returning home Laura goes to
freshen up when she is startled to see
the Align towel she hurriedly walks out
and begins checking the entire house
shortly after she opens the kitchen
shelf and is relieved to see the stuff
in a messed up state that night Laura
spends some private time with Ben in the
garden the pairs share a romantic kiss
before bidding each other good night
Upon returning to her house Laura
notices her closet is open alarmed she
hurries to the kitchen and checks the
Shelf only to discover that the contents
are lined up to Martin's exacting
standards knowing that her fears have
come true she starts crying when she is
ultimately confronted by Martin he hugs
and kisses her expressing relief at
touching her after a prolonged absence
in the midst of this Ben knocks on the
door and reminds Laura of the time to
meet tomorrow when he senses something a
Miss he breaks into the house and
attempts to subdue Martin however he is
easily overpowered and knocked
unconscious Martin then shows Laura her
wedding ring and begins kissing her
forcefully just then she slams her knee
into his balls grabs his firearm and
holds him at gunpoint as she reaches the
phone to call the police Martin
anticipates that she is just threatening
him and she has done in the past but
this time she shocks him by informing
the police she has killed an intruder
moments later she shoots him three times
in the chest causing him to collapse to
the ground following the incident Laura
breaks into tears when Martin suddenly
wakes up like a zombie and aims the gun
at her in a desperate attempt to kill
kill her fortunately the gun clicks
empty and he succumbs to his wounds the
movie ends as Laura and Ben Embrace and
wait for the police to arrive subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching